สวัสดีค่ะครูนิดสวัสดีครับครูเรียม
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียน
วันนี้เราเจอกันวันอะไรคะครูนิวันนี้ครับ
วันพุธที่
อะไรคะ
วันที่ 16
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนตุลาคมครับ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
[เพลง]
ตอนนี้ที่อเมริกา
กี่โมงแล้วคะเดี๋ยวนี้
ตอนนี้นะครับที่นี่เวลา 9 โมง
กาแฟหรือยังคะกำลัง
[เพลง]
ดื่ม
ดื่มที่ประเทศไทยตอน 3 ทุ่ม 38
ยังไงเดี๋ยวก็หลับ
ไปนอนก่อนไหม
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ใช่เพราะว่าที่นั่นแต่ตอนกลางคืนแล้วผู้
เรียนนะ
แบบสดใสมากเลย
แต่เวลาที่แบบมีคลิปที่บันทึกตอนกลางวัน
เรียนก็จะแบบตาหรือมาก
ก็จริงๆ
จะไม่ค่อยมีแรงจะดูแบบ
ไม่จะดูเหมือนแบบไม่พร้อมตอนเช้าๆเพราะ
ว่าเมื่อก่อนอยู่กลางคืนนอนดึกแบบตี 3
ค่อยนอนประมาณนี้
[เพลง]
แต่ก็แบบรู้สึกสดชื่นชอบทำงานตอนดึกๆ
ดูตอนนี้ผมเล็บยาวมาก
ยาวแล้วครูเรียมชอบไว้ผมยาวนี่ใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะชอบไว้ผมยาว
แล้วเมื่อก่อน
เมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนทำสีผม
กับสีน้ำตาล
แล้วตอนนี้ก็แบบผมยาว
สีน้ำตาลเนี่ย
ตัดออกไปหมดแล้วอันนี้ผมดำจริงๆผมจริงๆ
ถุงเดียว
แล้ว
พอย้อมผม
ครูเรียมชอบย้อมผมไหม
ชอบย้อมผม
ใช่เพราะเวลาย้อมผมแล้วรู้สึกว่าหน้ามัน
จะแบบสว่างมีออร่าขึ้นมา
แล้วย้อมบ่อยแค่ไหนครับ
เพราะคิดว่าถ้าจะย้อมผมหรือว่าเปลี่ยนสี
ผมน่าจะไปที่กรุงเทพฯ
เพราะรู้จักร้านทำผมที่นั่นใช่
พูดดีว่าแบบ
สำหรับเรียนนะเรียมคิดว่า
ถ้ารินจะย้อมสีให้แบบมันอ่อนๆแบบพวกสี
บรอนซ์สีอะไรอ่ะสีชมพู
สีเขียว
ต้องไปที่ร้านที่เขาเก่งๆอ่ะใช่พวกสีที่
มันสว่างสว่างสีเออจริงๆจริงๆแล้วเนี่ย
เราพูดว่าเป็นสีที่มัน
ตรงข้ามกับสีที่เรามีดีกว่าเพราะว่าอัน
นี้กับคุณนิดรู้เพราะว่าคุณนี้คือย้อมผม
บ่อยใช้คำว่าบ่อยเลยแหละเราคนนี้ก็มี
เพื่อนที่ย้อมผมคือเน้นมีเพื่อนที่ทำร้าน
ทำผมเขาก็จะบอกว่าสมมุติคนไทยเนี่ยผมสีดำ
สีเข้มแล้วเราอยากจะย้อมผมสีบลอนด์สีทอง
สีที่มันอ่อนๆแบบสว่างๆ
ถ้ายอมเอง
มันไม่ง่ายต้องให้คนที่มีความรู้ที่รู้
ว่ามันต้องย้อนยังไงเพราะถ้าอยากได้สีผม
ที่สว่างมันจะต้องใช้น้ำยาพวกสารเคมีที่
มันกัดผมก่อนให้มันสีขาวแล้วก็ให้ย้อมสี
ที่อยากใส่เข้าไป
อยากได้สีแบบชมพูฟ้าม่วงยูนิคอร์นไปเลย
อ่ะ
จริงๆก็ลองทนดู
คิดว่าได้อยู่นะ
นะแล้วพรุ่งนี้ล่ะคะคนนี้เคยทำสีสว่างๆ
ไหมแบบย้อมผมอ่ะ
เคยเคยครับแต่ก็คือ
คุณนิคเนี่ยที่บอกว่าย้อมผมบ่อยเนี่ยคือ
ย้อมผมทุกเดือน
เมื่อก่อนนะตอนนี้ตอนนี้จะย้อมประมาณทุก 2
เดือน
อ้าวทำไมทำไมเปลี่ยนเป็นนานมากขึ้น
เพราะว่าคือ
จริงๆแล้วคู่นี้ก็มีผมขาวตั้งแต่อายุแบบ
10 ขวบก็คือตั้งแต่เด็กแล้วเมื่อก่อน
เนี่ยคือไม่ชอบไม่ชอบผมขาวเพราะว่าเวลาไป
ไหนไปข้างนอกแล้วคนจะมองว่าแบบอ้าวนี่มัน
อายุเยอะแล้วนี่เพราะมีผมขาวแล้วคุณนิด
ไม่ได้อายุเยอะเพิ่งจะ 10 ขวบเองทำไมพูด
แบบนี้ร้องไห้ไปหาแม่
[เพลง]
แต่ก็ไม่ได้ย้อมผมจนเข้ามาหาวิทยาลัยนะ
เพราะแม่คุณนิไม่ให้แม่คุณนิบอกว่าอยาก
ย้อมผมก็ย้อมผมตอนอายุ 18
เพราะว่าแม่ก็ไม่อยากให้ใช้สารเคมีตั้ง
แต่เด็กใช่ๆครับก็เลยย้อมผมพอเข้ามา
มหาวิทยาลัยปีแรกย้อมเลย
ย้อมสีอะไรก็ตอนแรกๆก็สีดำครับ
เพราะว่าผมมันยาวแล้วมันก็เห็นผมขาวก็
เปลี่ยนสีไปเรื่อยๆก็ตอนนั้นตอนนั้นก็จะ
ย้อมสีที่
แม่คุณนิยอมเพราะว่าไม่อยากซื้อสีย้อมผม
ไม่อยากเสียเงินเองก็ไปใช้ของเหลือจากแม่
เพราะว่าของคุณนี่ผมมันสั้นอยู่แล้วไง
ครับ
ผมคุณนี่มันมีแค่นี้
ถ้าเกิดว่าซื้อยาย้อมผมเนี่ยมาย้อมผมเอง
ที่บ้านใช้มากสุดก็แค่ครึ่งกล่อง
เข้าใจแล้วเพราะว่าผมของครูนิกสั้น
ผมของเรียนเวลาเรียนย้อมครั้งนึงนะใช้
ทั้งหมดเลย
ถ้าเกิดว่าเราซื้อ
น้ำยาย้อมผมมาย้อมเองที่บ้านนะ
[เพลง]
ให้เพื่อนยอมให้
เป็นการย้อมครั้งแรกในชีวิตเลยเรียนย้อน
สีน้ำตาลอ่อน
มันจะเป็นแบบคล้ายๆแบบนี้
คล้ายๆแบบนี้หรือเปล่า
คล้ายๆแบบนี้
แล้วเป็นยังไง
ก็ชอบนะ
ชอบแต่เวลาโดนแสงแดดน่ะมันจะแบบสว่างมาก
แล้วพี่สาวเรียมไม่รู้เขาพูดเล่นหรือ
เปล่านะเขาบอกว่ายอมเลือกโดนแดดแล้ว
เหมือนแบบไปเลี้ยงควายเลย
เหมือนแบบเหมือนแบบโดนแสงแดดเยอะเหมือนผม
ที่โดนแสงแดดเยอะอะไรอย่างนี้
แล้วมันแบบน้ำตาลแล้วแบบมันสีสว่างแดงๆ
อะไรอย่างเงี้ย
เหมือนผมเสีย
เพราะว่าบางทีคนที่เลี้ยงควายเขาก็แบบตาก
แดดแล้วแบบผมโดนแสงแล้วผมเสีย
เราก็เลยแบบรู้สึกไม่มั่นใจ
ก็
สำหรับครูนิคเนี่ยคือคุณนิดก็จะย้อมสีที่
แม่คุณนิดย้อมเพราะแม่คนนี้ก็ชอบย้อมผม
เขาจะย้อมผมบ่อยอยู่แล้วแล้วก็คือแม่คุณ
นิดเนี่ยจะชอบย้อมผมสีสว่างเกิดจากสีแดง
สีทองบางครั้งก็จะสีม่วง
ก็ช่วงช่วงนั้นเนี่ยก็จะอยู่ประมาณนี้
ครับสีสว่างๆ
แบบนี้เลยหรอ
วันนี้ก็แบบผมสีเดียวกันกับแม่
ใช่ๆวันนี้ก็ย้อมไปแต่ก็จะมีบางครั้งที่
เพราะคุณนิดย้อมผมเนี่ยถ้าผมสีสว่างคนนี้
ก็จะย้อมคิ้วด้วย
[เพลง]
เพราะมันตลกว่าโอ้โหผมทองเลยแต่คิ้วดำ
ใช่ๆครั้ง
มีจุดดำตรงนี้เออมันตลกคุณนิดก็เลยโอเคก็
ยอมทั้งหมดแต่คิ้วเนี่ย
จะ
ปกติคุณนี้จะย้อมผมก็คือพอใส่น้ำยาย้อมผม
แล้วเนี่ยประมาณ 40  45 นาทีแล้วก็ไปล้าง
สระผมออกแต่ถ้าเป็นคิ้วเนี่ยจะเอาไว้
ประมาณ 15 นาที
น้อยกว่าน้อยกว่าเพราะว่าคือคุณเล็กแค่
กลัวว่าเดี๋ยวคิ้วมันจะหายเพราะว่า
ตรงนี้มันไม่ได้คือคิ้วเรามันไม่ได้แข็ง
แรงเหมือนผม
โอเคตรงนี้ให้มันเปลี่ยนสีอ่อนนิดนึงก็
โอเค
แต่บางคนน่ะย้อมผมย้อมคิ้วแล้วก็ใส่
คอนแทคเลนส์นะ
ย้อมผมสีอ่อนเนี่ยต้องแบบสีตาต้องเปลี่ยน
เป็นสีอ่อนด้วย
ก็ใช่ครับแต่ครูนิไม่ได้ไม่ได้ซีเรียส
ขนาดนั้น
แต่สำหรับบางคนน่ะเขาแบบบางคนก็บอกว่าหมด
เลย
ก็ต้องเป็นฝรั่งไปเลย
แล้วครูนิดย้อมผมบ่อยๆคุณรู้สึกว่าผมมัน
เสียไหม
รู้สึกแต่ครูนิคเนี่ยผมอีกอย่างนึงเนี่ย
คุณนิคผมมีแค่นี้แต่คุณนี้จะเป็นคนชอบ
สระผมมากคุณนิดก็จะมี
แชมพูยาสระผมแล้วก็
conditioner ก็คือเหมือนกับครีมที่นวดผม
คุณนิคเนี่ยในบ้านเนี่ยจะมียาสระผมประมาณ
2 ขวดแล้วก็ครีมนวดผมประมาณ 2-3 อันอัน
นี้ยังไม่รวมกับไอ้ตัว
ที่ตอนนี้เขาเรียกว่ามันเป็นมาร์คที่เอา
ไปมาร์คผมเคราตินอะไรอย่างนี้หรออะไรพวก
นั้นนะครับใช่
[เพลง]
คุณเองไม่ชอบเวลาผมเสียแล้วรู้ว่าต้อง
ย้อมผมบ่อยอยู่แล้วก็เลยมีเอาไว้ว่า
ให้ผมมันดูโอเคตลอดเวลาแล้วก็
ประมาณนั้นครับแล้วทีนี้ที่เปลี่ยนจาก
ย้อมทุก 1 เดือนเป็น 2 เดือนเหตุผลก็แค่
พออายุมากขึ้นเราเริ่มทำใจได้ว่าผมขาวมัน
ต้องมีและไม่อยากให้มันมีสารเคมีอยู่ใน
หัวเยอะก็เลยเปลี่ยนเป็น 2 เดือน
[เพลง]
รู้ไหมว่า
บางทีเรียมก็คิดนะว่าถ้าเกิดเราไม่อยาก
ย้อมผมเราแบบไปซื้อวิกมาใส่เห็นไหม
อาจจะเป็น 7 สี 7 วัน 7 สีเปลี่ยนวิกสี
บรอนซ์
สีน้ำตาล
จริงๆก็ดีคือ
พี่สาวคุณนิดทำแบบนั้น
ใช่เพราะพี่สาวครูนิดเนี่ยเขาเขาชอบย้อม
ผมเหมือนกันแต่ว่าบางครั้งเขารู้สึกว่า
เขาอยากย้อมเขาอยากมีผมสีชมพูแต่
แค่อยากมีผมสีชมพูไปข้างนอกครั้งสองครั้ง
อาจจะแบบวันนี้วันนี้วันเดียว
ใช่เขาก็เลย
ไปซื้อวิกมาดีกว่าง่าย
ใช่
อย่างนี้เดี๋ยวก็เห็นหลายคนนะที่ซื้อวิก
มาใส่แล้วก็เปลี่ยนสีผมข้างในเนี่ยก็แบบ
ไม่ต้องเสียด้วยไม่ต้องแบบโดนสารเคมี
วันไหนอยากใส่สีอะไรก็หยิบมาใส่
แค่นั้นเอง
คือนิเคยเอาจริงๆแล้วนะ
ไม่ได้ว่าใส่วิกในชีวิตประจำวันเคยลอง
เล่นก็คือเอาวิกของพี่สาวหรือเอาวิกของ
เพื่อนมาใส่เล่นอยากรู้ว่าเป็นยังไง
คุณนี้ทำไม่ชอบ
คือ
มันเจ็บหัว
คือมันเจ็บหัวเพราะว่าวิกผมเนี่ยพอมันใส่
เนี่ยมันจะต้องมีเขาเรียกเหมือนเป็นกิ๊บ
อ่ะใช่
หัวใช่เพราะว่าไม่งั้นวิกมันจะหลุด
ใช่ๆ
ใช่คุณถึงรู้สึกเจ็บ
คือเหมือนกับ
คือตอนนั้นน่ะคุณนิก็เด็กๆประมาณจริงๆก็
ไม่เด็กหรอกครับประมาณเรียนมหาวิทยาลัย
และอยากรู้ว่า
ถ้ามีผมยาวเนี่ยมันจะเป็นยังไง
เพราะเขาจะชอบเหมือนไปโชว์ตามงานอะไรพวก
นี้ครับแต่งตัวเขาก็จะมีวิกที่เป็นวิกยาว
เป็นลอนม้วนๆ
[เพลง]
วันหยุดไงไปเล่นบ้านเพื่อนก็เลยลองใส่
แล้วก็ออกไป
มันก็มันก็แปลกดีแต่
มันก็น่ามันก็พอเข้าใจผู้หญิงมากขึ้น
เพราะว่าเวลาผมยาวอ่ะแล้วผมมันมันปิดหน้า
เหมือนเดินๆอยู่แล้วลมพัดแล้วผมมันแบบ
เข้าป่า
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เดินไปสั่งข้าวมันไก่บอกพี่พี่เอาข้าวแบบ
เอาข้าวมันไก่ 1 ห่อแบบนี้มัน
มีผู้หญิงเขาไม่ได้ทำ
เวลาลมพัดผมเขาก็จะสะบัดสวยๆเขาจะแบบ
แบบนี้เขาไม่ใช่อะไรอย่างนี้มากของเรามัน
ครั้งแรกไงอะไรวะเออเข้าใจทำไมผมมันยาว
แล้ว
แต่คุณนิดก็กลัวว่าเพราะตอนนั้นเราใส่วิก
ไง
ถ้าเกิดไปทำวิกเพื่อนน่ะ
ถ้ามันพังขึ้นมาเนี่ย
เราต้องจ่ายเงินให้เพื่อนอีกแล้ววีคมัน
ไม่ได้ถูกนะ
แบบ
2,300 บาทนะ
ถ้าเกิดถูกๆก็มีราคาหลักร้อยนะแบบ 7  800
บาทแต่ก็เกือบพันเลยนะใช่ก็
เพิ่งนึกได้ครูนิคเคยคุณนิดเคยใส่วิกเป็น
วิกแบบหัวฟูพอเหมือนกับตอนมหาวิทยาลัยเขา
มีแต่งตัวเป็นเขาเรียกว่าอะไรมันก็เป็น
งานดิสโก้คุณนิดมาเป็นแบบหัวฟู Disco
แค่อันนั้นน่ะก็ก็สรุปดีแต่มันมันเป็นแบบ
หัวฟูแบบสั้นๆประมาณนี้
แค่นี้แต่ก็ใส่แป๊บเดียวก็โอเคใช่ไหม
ตอนนั้นน่ะก็คิดว่าแพงแล้วคือ 500 บาทยัง
จำได้เลย
ก็ราคาตอนนั้นก็ 15 ปีแล้วนะ
ไม่ใช่สิ
ตอนนั้นมันตีค.ศ
2006 พูดไปก็จะนานกว่านั้นนะ
16 ปีที่แล้ว 500 บาท
[เพลง]
แล้วใช้ครั้งเดียวทิ้ง
แต่ว่าสมัยนี้ผมยาวๆแบบนี้สมมุติว่าอัน
นี้เรียมใส่วิกนะยาวๆแบบนี้ก็ประมาณ 800
แบบถูกๆ
แบบถูกอะไรอย่างนี้
[เพลง]
ก็เดี๋ยวขอเช็คราคาก่อนเช็คราคาในแบบ
shopee  Lazada ก่อนว่าผม
วิกผมที่แบบเปลี่ยนสีแล้วอ่ะมันจะถูกหรือ
แพง
หรือว่าแบบจะคิดหรือว่าจะย้อมผมดีอะไร
อย่างนี้
พูดถึงย้อมผมแล้ว
เพราะคุณนิคเนี่ยจะย้อมผมเองตลอด
มันมีแค่นี้ไปร้านเราเสียดายเงิน
ก็
คือเรียมเคยเป็นไหมว่าถ้าย้อมผมเองที่
บ้านแล้วมันจะมีพวกสีผม
ติดตามหูหน้าผากแบบนี้
มีน้อยอ่ะ
ย้อมสีสว่างนั่นแหละมันก็เลยแบบติดตรงนี้
แล้วมันมองไม่ค่อยเห็นแต่ถ้าเกิดย้อนสีดำ
สีดำยังเคยยอมให้ป้าเหลี่ยมสีดำมันจะติด
เนี่ยติด
กรอบหน้า
มันมีวิธีนะมันมีวิธีที่ไม่ให้ติดคือคุณ
นิคเนี่ยก่อนจะย้อมผมคุณนี้จะใช้วาสลีน
เอาวาสลีนมาป้ายคือเขาก็บอกว่าแค่ป้ายขอบ
ๆแต่คุณนิดกลัวไงเพราะคุณนิดย้อนผมเองนะ
ป้ายทางหน้าผากเลย
สรุปแล้วน้ำยามาหยดจมูก
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
มันก็จะไม่เปื้อนเพราะคุณนี้จะคือทุกวัน
นี้คุณนิดจะย้อมผมแค่สีดำแต่เป็นสีดำแบบ
สีดำน้ำตาล
ไหนๆก็ย้อมผมแล้วสีดำอย่างเดียวไม่โอเค
อยากให้มันเป็นสีดำน้ำเงินที่แบบเป็นสีดำ
ที่คนเห็นแล้วคิดว่าอันนี้ไม่ใช่สี
ธรรมชาติ
นิดนึงอะไรอย่างนี้
สีดำแบบใส่วิก
อ้าวใช่แล้วก็แบบยังไงเราก็ได้คุยกัน
เรื่องย้อมสีผมแล้วแหละนักเรียนอยากเห็น
ไหมว่าเวลาเรียนย้อมสีผมแล้วมันจะเป็นยัง
ไง
ที่ว่าเวลาถ่ายรูปแล้วผมมันจะเปลี่ยนสี
อ่ะครูเรียมก็ลองดูแล้วก็จะได้รู้ว่าอ๋อ
ถ้าเกิดสีนี้เนี่ยมันจะเข้ากับหน้าไหมคุณ
นิดเคยทำ
ต้องไปลองค่ะ
ใช่เดี๋ยวเป็นยังไงถ้าเกิดแบบได้ไปย้อมมา
จริงๆนักเรียนก็คงจะได้เห็นในช่องนี้อยู่
ดีในช่องนี้
ก็ดูว่านักเรียนคิดว่าดีหรือไม่ดี
comment ไม่ได้นะอยากให้ย้อมสีอะไรสี
ยูนิคอร์นอะไรอย่างนี้ใช่
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
หมดเวลาแล้วค่ะต้องเจอกันในคลิปหน้านะคะ
ทุกคนใช่ครับโอเคไว้เจอกันใหม่ครับสวัสดี